buongiorno è venuta al prezioso te lo
small luxury boutique resort and spa il
suo nome cagarella anna eccola qua ok le
ha prenotato una double con for luxury
room per due notti giusto purtroppo non
ha la vista mare però una fantastica
park in via laterale dal quale vi del
parcheggio riservato agli ospiti no
signora non ho altri stanziate les paul
siamo fule dallo scorso gennaio per
scusarci del disguido li offriamo
fantastico bicchieri di tavernelle si
riserva di benvenuto enjoy e la sua
camera non è ancora pronta si abbia
avuto un super double lei checkout
nell'attesa però per scusarsi
dell'inconveniente proprio lì nel tavolo
di davanti troverà una fantastica
selezione di sandwich di due giorni fa
precisamente selezionati dal nostro
mentre c'è qualche la colazione vere
ferita dalle 4 45 le 7 in un quarto del
mattino nel palazzo che trova in fondo
la via si sveglia più tardi non c'è
nessun problema le lasceremo davanti
alla porta una ciotola di latte con del
grosso di di pane come servizio
complementari e scuse seconda buongiorno
sono marina per quante notti
sfortunatamente siamo a completo fino al
2029 una stazza libre ci sarebbe sì ma è
la suite royale e imperial dell'acs
extralarge 100 days ottica 3.498 euro
notte ma si figuri arrivederci